and there we have it the winner of
Fabiano Carano with an additional 13
Grand Chester points $440,000 Victory
with a final round draw against Maxim
Vash gra who finished uh at second place
both these players clearly the best
performers in the two days blit and as
Fabby said that he needed a little bit
of help from Maxim because he was in
such a good position at the start of the
day with two extra points a two-point
lead uh but it was not meant to be and
then we see Yana pomi and Liam for third
Yi gets an additional 7 and a half Grand
Chester points alza finished fifth the
world number one Blitz player and that
just shows how difficult this field was
and uh with this of course we've got one
more event and we've got wesle so in
7eventh place and this is after all of
that where we stand with our grand chest
standings Fabiano is not only really
happy with his result of the St Louis
rapid and bits but this puts him at such
a great spot for that $100,000 bonus at
the end of the season